This video is brought to you by wix
villains.
Oftentimes,
the best part of a movie can't live with
them,
can't feed them to a pack of rabid
hyenas.
Usually villains are the people we love
to hate or fear with the occasional
motor.
Come have empathy,
but something has been happening with
villains lately.
If you found yourself nodding along to
the logic of a diabolical plot or
feeling more empathetic than usual
towards a film's antagonist,
you're not alone.
Today's villains from killmonger and
Black Panther to screen slaver and
incredible to have become weirdly
relatable,
each equipped with their own cogent
critiques of the world.
People will trade quality for ease every
time.
Villainy is and always has been a
reflection of the value systems and
fears of the time.
So how did we get from this to this and
what does it say about our past and our
world today,
or we're gonna find out in this
wisecrack addition on the cinematic
history of villainy and warning.
There's a ton of spoilers here for
movies,
both old and new,
but before we do that,
want to give a quick shout out to our
sponsor over at Wix,
whether you're a hero,
a villain,
or a guy who makes philosophy videos on
youtube,
everyone needs a website and which gives
you the tools to make one that doesn't
look like Comic Sans and Papayas had a
baby,
wakes has the solutions for all your
Creator needs,
from launching an online store to
embedding videos of yourself,
eating donuts,
whatever your dream is,
weeks keeps your site secure and your
design possibilities infinite so you can
build out a website that's actually what
you want pretty fast.
It's totally free to sign up seriously
at [inaudible] dot com slash wise crack
or by clicking the link in the
description and now onto the villainy.
To understand how we got here,
we have to explore multiple arrows and
see how film villains embody the spirit
and anxieties of the times.
Now,
a quick disclaimer,
none of these trends are absolute
villains,
can break the mold or jump back into the
past for inspiration,
but what we're discussing here are
noticeable trends among some of the most
enduring films of each era.
We're going to start our journey from
these simple mustache twirling villain
to the complex philosophizing radical by
looking at the 19 fifties and early 19
sixties,
the height of the war that wasn't hot in
the post World War party in the suburbs
era of American history describing our
world seemed pretty simple.
We were the heroes who saved the world
from the evil Nazis,
and we're now tasked with staving off
the also evil Ussr.
It was very black and white,
and so where are villains?
Well,
yeah,
literally,
but also metaphorically movie screens
were full of bad Russian people,
bad Asian people,
and very bad aliens.
What do all these naughty dudes have in
common?
They're the other inherent,
inexplicably evil that stoked on
destroying America and our apple pie
values sometimes that other took the
form of an amorphous read for Kami blob
or the creature from the black lagoon.
Other times the other was an alien
hatched in a pod and designed to look
exactly like you as in the invasion of
the body snatchers,
which some critics say represented the
fear of communist brainwashing and
infiltration,
and you're reborn into an untroubled
exactly what a world.
Also in the fifties,
the movie industry went way back to
basics British thing,
a number of biblical Sagas with running
times of four hours or more of these
expensive epics proved massively popular
with three ranking in the top 10 highest
grossing films of the decade.
Perhaps this was partially because they
so perfectly embodied cold war
propaganda which depicted a face off
between God fearing Americans and the
godless communist Ben Hur showed an
aristocratic Jews being persecuted by an
Evil Roman commander while quo Vadis
pits.
New Christian converts against the Evil
Emperor Nero and his Roman Empire.
A world is mine and mine,
and the 10 commandments depicts good old
Moses staring down the Egyptian Emperor
Ramses.
These films all portrayed the Noble
Judeo Christian taking on a cruel,
powerful,
desperate of a non monotheistic
religion.
These villains were representative of
larger groups of bad people who want it
to cancel baseball.
Tupperware parties,
rain is not only been washed as they
say,
just being dry,
clean,
even when villains weren't explicitly
foreign or pagan.
They were just anti American communists,
double agents as seen in a flurry of
cold war propaganda films later spy
mania of the 19 sixties would also
reflect cold war anxiety with James Bond
facing off against various agents have
smashed the imaginary Russian
intelligence agency not to remain that
much longer.
What all these movies had in common was
an US versus them mentality with no good
commies portrayed as pure and simply
evil.
One dimensional foreign slash communist
slash alien slash blog villains took a
backseat in the late sixties and
seventies as we saw a definitive shift
in the portrayal of villains.
It was fitting for a time of major
social turbulence and soul searching.
As the civil rights movement and Vietnam
made visible,
some of the not so perfect aspects of
America like racism and war,
this period also saw a startling drop in
public trust of government,
a phenomenon that changed movie villains
dramatically as outrage over the war met
outrage about Nixon's tapes.
Notably 19 seventies movies shined a
light on the corrupt social systems that
Americans were increasingly
disillusioned with.
Evil politicians and public officials
loomed large popular political thriller.
All the president's men brought the
Watergate scandal to the big screen in
1976.
Fictional accounts also touched on
institutional corruption like in Steven
Spielberg's jaws,
which depicts a crooked mayor who cares
more about tourism revenue then keeping
people from becoming shark bait.
For Christ's sake,
Kumar's the fourth of July at we will be
open for business.
It's going to be one of the best summers
we've ever had.
Further depictions,
the evil in mighty came in Chinatown in
which these sinister billionaire rejects
audiences judgments of him by claiming
that his evil acts were brought about by
his environment.
People never have to face the fact the
right time,
the right place,
they're capable of anything.
The suggestion is that circumstances
have power make the villain rather than
any innate nature.
Corrupt cop films where another popular
way of portraying the power struggles
taking place serpico based on a true
story,
depicts a world in which police
corruption is an assumed fact.
You're fine,
you're fine without a warning,
right in your head.
In this world,
bribes and brutality are the coffee and
donuts of police work,
so much so that Alba,
Chino Serpico,
is distrusted because he's not willing
to accept bribes.
Let's face it,
who can dress the cabin?
We don't take money.
Corrupt cops were mainstays on the big
screen popping up in the Godfather,
white lightening,
the French connection and the
conversation to name a few institutions,
it seems had lost their presumption of
goodwill,
and as a result,
we started seeing villains who embodied
the very broken systems.
People were angry about take nurse
ratchet from one flew over the cuckoo's
nest who turned a benevolent profession
into one that turns a vivid individuals
into drugged up dependent ghosts of
themselves.
You're no crazier in the average ass
flat walking around on the streets and
that's it.
In a similarly bleak depiction of
institutionalization.
Escape from Alcatraz renders prisoners
sympathetic heroes struggling against
the efforts of an evil warden.
Something very similar can be seen in
cool hand luke.
In all these cases,
the person tasked with imposing law and
order or societal norms is recast as the
villain.
The 19 seventies further muddied the
waters by blurring the line between hero
and villain and told the distinctions
became all but meaningless.
These characters are depicted as
conflicted,
heavily flawed protagonists with
questionable even hideous morals in
Martin Scorsese's.
Nineteen 76 film taxi driver,
Travis bickle is one such heroic villain
or villain is hero depending on your
perspective.
He swings on the pendulum of violently
bad to violently good ish as it goes
from plotting to gun down a presidential
candidate,
the plotting to rescue a 12 year old
prostitute in the previous years.
Dog Day,
afternoon,
novice crook and hero slash villain
Sunny Warcek botches,
a bank robbery and spontaneously takes
all the workers hostage.
However,
we soon learned the reason for sunny's
dalliance with crime.
He needed the money to help his wife,
Leon get sexual reassignment surgery
right away.
Sonny wanted to get me money for the sex
change operation,
but when is he going to get it?
We find out that sunny is a quality dude
who pays his parents rent and doesn't
typically go around holding up banks,
not your villain of the past.
Meanwhile,
one particularly popular series.
Star wars stands out as markedly
simplistic in this era of more complex
villains.
It might seem to counter our theory as
it presents a pretty basic black and
white paradigm of good versus evil,
even if it goes against the grain later
on with he walks reminiscent of the Viet
Cong.
The 19 eighties backpedaled hard on the
anti villain by reveling in more
cartoonish villains who directly
embodied the biggest threats of time
effectively,
it ushered back in an US versus them
paradigm by tapping into the fear
surrounding the war on drugs.
Unsurprisingly,
the villains of the time wanted a piece
of that sweet,
sweet drug money in films like scarface
to live and die in La.
Beverly Hills cop and raw deal,
this depiction of evil drug lords could
be seen as a Yin Yang response to the
less than savory cops of the seventies.
Films Take Tango and cash,
which depicted to roguish cops who are
treated as irrepressible protagonists
despite engaging in some of the exact
same violence,
serpico condemned,
however they're portrayed as the best
cops in the city because they're
unconventional.
Tactics have costs.
Local drug lord and rat kissing villain
Eve's Perrey oodles of money then said
kingpin,
as if schooled in the bad cup films of
the seventies gets them falsely
incriminated for murder.
The film ultimately comes down hard on
the side of cops and a by any means
necessary model of policing.
I've been a policeman for 12 years and I
think it's the best organization in the
country.
At the same time,
the decade saw the resurgence of cold
war anxieties as president Ronald Reagan
increased military spending and ended
arms control.
Americans rediscovered their fear of
nuclear war.
At the same time,
evil Russians had their moment in the
sun with films like rocky,
for which remain the highest grossing
sports flick until 2009.
It's also been accused of being pure
anti Soviet propaganda because of its
villain Soviet boxer,
Ivan Drago,
who was decidedly not a charmer,
the film red heat,
really one the villain jackpot in its
depiction of Soviet drug lord Victor
Rostow,
who in a Trifecta of evil also murdered
the protagonist partner,
but arguably the clearest example of 19
of these cold war villains came with
1984 is red dawn,
which imagine Soviet forces invading
America and worse,
taking photos in our national parks.
The film's director,
John Milius,
explicitly saw the film as a warning to
Americans to take seriously the threat
of the Soviet invasion by a Central
America.
And if this seems like a scaremonger for
you,
consider that Melius was the direct
inspiration for this guy multimode
front,
you're entering a world of pain despite
some return to the other as the enemy.
There are hints of the seventies
skepticism towards institutions in the
19 eighties when villains are not pure
character traits.
From an Ansi Reagan fever dream,
we see them continue exploiting corrupt
institutions for personal gain.
Gordon greed is good.
Gecko,
for instance,
uses the corrupt financial industry to
fulfill his own gold plated desires.
Meanwhile,
diehards,
Hans Gruber,
emerges as one for decades.
Most enduring villains,
when he and his cronies sees a high rise
building and take hostages during a
Christmas party,
operates under the guise of being a
terrorist,
exacting revenge on an Evil Corporation
director.
The Naca trauma corporations legacy
agreed around the globe.
They are about to be taught a lesson in
the real useful,
but interestingly enough,
his moral high ground crumbled when it's
revealed that just like Gordon Gekko,
he's really only after cold hard cash.
This is all about the robbery.
The whole building odds are under $600.
You can just disappear when you still
$600 million.
They will find you unless you're already
dead.
In the nineties,
American cinema swapped out the reds for
homegrown terrorists to fit a decade in
which domestic terrorism and going
postal dominated headlines Fittingly in
cinema.
It was an era of disgruntled Middleclass
dudes and bombers next door,
a prime time for complex anti villains
who are fighting small localized battles
by radical means,
take the villain from speed.
Howard Payne,
this former bomb squad officer turned
extortionist,
turned psychopathic.
Terrorists is partially motivated by
that suite.
Three point $7,000,000,
but he also expresses a sense of
superiority.
You still don't get it,
dad,
Jack,
a bomb was made to explode.
That's its meaning,
its purpose.
That's bananas,
but it's a hint of philosophy,
a motivation beyond cold,
hard cash.
Howard's more complicated than say
gruber,
in that he genuinely desires meaning and
purpose.
It just goes about getting them in the
worst way possible.
Same goes for Kevin Spacey,
supremely sadistic John Doe in the 1995
films,
seven who sees himself as a chosen
warrior in the crusade against everyday.
Since
we see a deadly sin on every street
corner in every home and we tolerate it,
we tolerate it because it's common
sense.
It's trivial.
We tolerate it.
Morning,
noon,
and night.
Well,
not anymore.
I'm setting the example.
By the end of the decade,
Arlington Road became the pinnacle of
the domestic terrorists genre,
who's villain mans the girl at the block
party as he carries out plans for his
militant groups,
latest deadly bombing.
I'm a mess.
There's millions of waiting to take up
arms ready to spread the word.
He claims to be pursuing a lofty noble
goal,
but within his critique of government is
also an indictment of the supposed
niceties of Clinton era prosperity.
Are you happy in your godless
trouble in suburbia?
Also bounded in American beauty which
depicted the enemy as lester's neighbor
be homophobic.
Nazi memorabilia.
Hoarding Frank Fits who kills Lester
after he rebuffs his romantic
advancements.
In both cases,
the villains feel victimized by the
system or circumstance and seek justice
on their own terms.
Sometimes these villains have genuinely
noble causes as they rail against the
systems that have long take.
Nineteen 95.
The Rock in which Ed Harris has general
humble,
a disgraced USFC.
SMC Brigadier General threatens a nerve
gas attack on San Francisco.
15 vx gas rockets into the hardest San
Francisco.
You've got 17 hours to deliver the
money,
demanding that the families have slain
marines be compensated for their deaths.
Here we come to an interesting question
of whether noble ends justified by what
means in this way,
the film acts as a prelude to the
questions being explored by current day
villains,
though usually on a much wider scale,
movies couldn't not be changed by an
event as pivotal as nine slash 11 and
the subsequent war on terror with the
two thousands came a new shift in movie
villains,
as America confronted an existential
threat to its sense of safety and power
in the world.
Fittingly the first two installments of
Christopher Nolan's dark knight trilogy
captured the Popular Imagination.
In this decade.
In 2005 Batman begins,
we see the dangerous metropolis under
attack by an international terrorist
group called the League of shadows and
its leader rouse.
Oh,
cool.
Who in remarkably on the nose metaphor,
wants to blow up Gotham's tallest
skyscraper.
Arguably the decades most salient
villain came,
of course,
with Heath Ledger's portrayal of the
joker in the dark knight.
The joker manifests as the spirit of
terrorism,
the embodiment of anarchy and chaos of a
particularly destructive and nihilistic
nature.
As critic Douglas Kellner writes in his
book,
Cinema Wars,
the only sensible way to live in this
world is without rules in case the
comparison between the joker and real
world terrorism wasn't clear enough.
Calendar notes that the film is bursting
with nine slash 11 iconography.
Nolan's film also gave us one of two
coin flipping evildoers with the
character of Harvey Dent alias to face,
a representation of how a confrontation
with the joker's evils can corrupt even
the noblest person to face goes about
deciding people's fates,
do a plunge into a completely
meaningless existence of pure
contingency and nihilism.
Meanwhile,
the Coen brothers,
Anton sugar from no country for old men
also uses a coin to decide the fate of
his victims.
He doesn't kill out of greed self or
some kind of practical goal.
Leading one character to comment is a
peculiar man might even say he has
principles transcend money or drugs or
anything like that.
Indeed,
sugar is quite simply an active
nihilists who believes that if all
morality is contrived,
a coin flip is as good a way as any to
decide who lives and dies,
but you don't need a coin to affirm the
random or meaningless nature of our
lives are deaths.
Take Martin Scorsese's 2006,
film the departed,
which featured Jack Nicholson as chief
gangster Frank Costello from merciless
killing.
She felt funny to his refusal to
subscribe to any rules.
I don't want to be a product of my
environment.
I want my environment to be a product of
me.
Frank's action seems shaped by the
belief that life is meaningless as you
will act accordingly.
Frank,
who we later find out was an FBI
informant sees life as one long struggle
during which any actions that sustain
you for just one more day are entirely
excusable.
Of course,
plenty of other villain archetypes
punctuated the two thousands,
but if the two thousands where a time
when the villain is creed was no credit
at all.
We've come a long way since then.
Today are villains are the product of an
increasingly divided America bracing
itself for impact with trust in
government,
media,
and religious faith at all time.
Lows,
villains reflect America's innate
skepticism towards systems.
Any systems,
all the systems villain simply embody
solutions that are way too radical and
usually mind bogglingly violent,
the polar opposite of a 19 fifties
villain who represented an evildoer
infiltrating and inherently good system
in hopes of corrupting it.
Today's villains increasingly face
objectively evil systems which they want
to change for the better.
The only thing that makes these
characters villains rather than starry
eyed heroes is their means of carrying
out that change.
You agree to end the war on drugs once
and for all.
My colleagues and I received full legal
immunity.
The classic caveat of,
Hey man,
you'd be really cool if we weren't
trying to kill half the world.
For instance,
Black Panthers killmonger played by
Michael B.
Jordan has an entirely legitimate
critique of how the world treats its
black citizens and will conduct past
severity as they suffer.
In fact,
killmonger would argue that the real
villains of the film are Wakandans who
sit on a stockpile of vibranium while
pretending to be a helpless third world
country.
We're killmonger is perspective gets
debatably.
Tricky is in the means.
He wants to ship bill condon weapons all
over the world and instigate a militant
uprising.
The world's going to start over,
and this time we're on top.
The Sun will never set on the will.
Conduct empire,
though to Cholla defeats him and stops
the scheme.
He does go to the UN to admit Wakanda's
real capacities and even establishes a
candy and outreach center in Oakland
suggesting an end to Wakanda is
isolationism.
So killmonger is radicalism,
actually brought about a less radical
but positive change in policy.
Then there's mission impossible.
Six is new utilitarian villain,
August walker slash jog Lark,
who wants to destroy a third of the
world in the hopes that the other two
thirds would come together in the wake
of the attacks,
or as he says,
there's never been peace without first
the great suffering or the suffering
that created the piece or if it any
worse than those who wants to kill half
of everyone to solve resource scarcities
that play for universe or incredibles,
two's bill and screen slaver.
We use uses hypnotic screens to mind,
control her minions or personal beef
with the system that the endless
repackaging of life into consumable
media has made us all lazy.
Passive observers and that superheroes
are an integral part of the equation,
keeping us docile and meet her plan to
change the system.
Mind control superheroes and ruined
their public approval rating so people
will learn that they have to protect
themselves.
What all these villains share is a
majorly out their plan that appeals to
our country's growing fears.
That the world is screwed beyond repair
and the only way to fix it is to tear it
all down.
In this brave new world of villainy,
we're able to,
with the villains critique of the system
and their desire to change it.
In this through the looking glass
reinterpretation of Villainy,
the heroes are almost inevitably cast as
slightly flawed protectors of the status
quo that no one's really happy with.
In the grand scheme of things,
contemporary villains seemed to be a
weird mirror image of fifties villains
who want to corrupt good institutions.
Whereas killmonger types want to effect
good change in corrupt institutions.
They just go about it in very bad ways.
At the same time,
our contemporary villain seemed to have
merged the complexity and sometimes
apparent innocence of nineties villains
while broadening the social critiques of
the seventies and standing in opposition
to the nihilism of the two thousands.
They do believe that there's a cause
worth fighting for,
and if they drafted different blueprints
for creating social change,
they might just resurface as complex
heroes.
So what do you guys think are today's
villains more interesting than past evil
doers?
And what do you think will come next for
Hollywood bad guts?
Let us know in the comments and as
always,
guys,
piece and before you go,
another shout out to wigs.
If you're thinking about making a
website,
wix is the ticket for something that
doesn't just look professional.
It actually does everything you want it
to.
It's free to get started and the
possibilities are endless.
You can set up a blog about yams and
online shirt store that only sells shoes
or a hotel booking site for your
roommate's room and you can get started
for free.
Just click here or visit [inaudible] dot
com slash wise crack.
And until next time guys.
Hey.